I
Oh kijima you know he just really speaks
to me I mean aren't we all just bipedal
killing machines but with the innocent
hearts of naked snakes you're getting
this I mean what's your interpretation
you need me to explain it to you I mean
it's pretty obvious all right man Fox
agent naked snake has dropped into the
Soviet Union after its discovered that
his ex mentor the boss has defected and
given nukes to a Soviet Colonel called
volgen these WMDs are used to destroy a
Soviet facility so two whole world war
three snake has to stop the boss and
take out a metal gear would help from
another defector Eva snake learns about
the Philosopher's the world's most
powerful and richest men and they're
cool but missing 100 billion dollar
legacy everyone including the US wants
it after destroying the metal gear and
volgen and shortly after getting his I
punched out by notorious double-crosser
Ocelot snake defeats the boss he and Eva
get it on but she leaves revealing that
she's trying to secure the legacy for
China and that the boss wasn't a traitor
after all feeling a bit messed around by
his country our hero now called big boss
leaves Fox Fox goes rogue and the u.s.
now in possession of half the legacy
charges big boss and his ex co major
zero with treason to clear their names
team Snake Eater need to capture gene
Fox's leader jean has been convinced by
the Pentagon to fire a new cat the USSR
to keep the Cold War going but off salon
changes his mind and aims it at the u.s.
to destroy the philosophers and create a
military nation armies heaven big boss
goes in defeats metal gear and gene who
gives up armies heavens resources
afterwards big boss Ocelot and major 0
form the Patriots their own philosophers
with big boss at the head bebe gets
injured and 0 clones him understandably
miffed big boss goes off in a huff and
create smirk band militare son frontier
who get hired to investigate a
mysterious military presence in costa
rica turns out there's a metal gear
named peace walker with an AI based on
the boss the CIA want to use the metal
gear to ensure retaliation in the event
of a nuclear attack but big boss
destroys it and then the AI decides to
drown itself because reasons
double-cross time major zero now
going by cypher sends an agent pass to
hijack big bosses metal gear and fire
nukes into the u.s. thus framing the msf
big boss obviously stopped her war is
averted and the msf is promised a new
land outer Haven has missing presumed
dead is found in camp Omega around the
same time the msf is preparing for a UN
inspection put on by site Bronco big
boss sneaks into Omega run by xof and
nab spars a little Chico as they're his
only links to cipher but there promptly
blown up by a bomb hidden in passes
insides and then snake ends up in a coma
for a few years and he wakes up and
there we have the phantom pain just
marvelous well that's the work of big
boss but personally i prefer the work of
Solid Snake real name's David don't you
know oh wow I didn't you know I'm not
really familiar with that time period I
lose track after the phantom pain
Renaissance well perhaps I can be of
some assistance
close enough chip chip chip chip inside
the bodies of bike Pete good all right
and then